Okay, von mir aus können wir loslegen.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist NSR Turck und ich bin zuständiger als für Sie in dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne heute mit Ihnen eine Gespräch durchführen.
Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Ist es auch noch für Sie?
Ja, das ist schon okay.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Frank Willers.
Frank Willers.
Können Sie mir bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist F-R-A-N-K.
Frank und der Familienname ist Willers.
W-I-L-L-E-R-S.
Okay. Frau Willers, ja?
Ja, ich bin ein Mann. Frank ist ein Männername.
Ah, ich schliebe. Herr Willers.
Willers, ja.
Herr Willers, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 41 Jahre alt.
41 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 2.02.1982.
Okay. 282.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
94 kg.
Krass 95.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84.
Herr Willers, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also, wissen Sie, ich wäre normalerweise ja nicht gekommen.
Aber, poh, ich habe seit 2 Stunden angefangen,
habe ich solche komischen Schmerzen hier oben,
so in der Brust, so hinterm Brustbein.
Und das sind ganz, ja, ganz schreckliche Schmerzen.
Und ich habe so ein enge Gefühl in der Brust.
Und beim Einatmen wird das immer noch schlechter.
Und ich habe gar nichts gemacht.
Also, ich kenne das wohl, so aus dem letzten,
aus dem ganzen letzten Jahr, da habe ich das immer mal gehabt,
wenn ich wirklich Stress hatte,
oder wenn ich mich sehr angestrengt habe,
wenn ich etwas Schweres getragen habe,
oder wenn ich eine Treppe hochgelaufen bin.
Aber jetzt ist es eigentlich so am Feierabend gekommen.
Poh, das sind solche Schmerzen, das macht mir richtig ein bisschen Angst.
Mir ist auch schlecht, muss ich sagen.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich Druckgefühl?
Ja, ich habe ein starkes, so ein enge Gefühl in der Brust, ja.
Okay, Herr Willers, muss ich jetzt unsere Gespräche unterbrechen
und dann Ihre Vizeparamette durchführen?
Ja, ich muss so als Ihre Blutdruck und Blutzuckerspiegel und Puls
und Sauerstoff in Blut messen.
Ja, das kann ich gut verstehen.
Okay, das haben Sie jetzt gemacht?
Und dann, es wäre schön, wenn ich auch eine Eke geschrieben würde.
Ja, klar.
Das machen wir jetzt alles, ne?
Und Sie sehen, dass ich also jetzt wieder lebe.
Dann können wir weitermachen, ja?
Dann können wir jetzt weitermachen, genau.
Okay.
Herr Willers, die Harbungen vermische ich immer,
als ich hinter der Brustbein habe,
und sie gesagt und Atelnot, aber sie haben gesagt,
sie haben endlich Bescheid, die wir gehabt haben.
Aber jetzt...
Ja, jetzt kam das so ganz plötzlich.
Das kam ohne, dass ich mich irgendwie angestrengt habe
und eigentlich so nach der Arbeit.
Eigentlich war ich schon zu Hause
und ich habe jetzt nicht irgendwie im Garten gearbeitet oder so.
Okay, per stehe.
Ja, deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich muss mal schnell hier zu Ihnen kommen.
Okay, alles klar.
Lustig begonnen.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen überhaupt oder übergeregt?
Also, jetzt sind sie schon ein bisschen besser.
Also, beim Anfang war das wirklich ziemlich, ziemlich kräftig die Schmerzen.
Jetzt sind sie noch da, aber nicht so schlimm.
Wie gesagt, beim Einatmen ist es eigentlich besonders unangenehm.
Und ja, jetzt ist halt so, dass mir auch schlecht ist
und dass ich das Gefühl habe, so, puh, das Herz klopft ganz schnell.
Herz klopft.
Ganz schnell.
Okay.
Herr Willers, wie sind die Schmerzen auch?
Die Schmerzen sind auch eine Schmerzkla von 1 bis 10.
Vorbei eines sehr leicht.
Um 10 unerfreuliches Beinspricht.
Also, am Anfang waren die sicherlich so bei 6 oder so.
Jetzt sind sie vielleicht so zwischen 3 und 4.
Okay, am Anfang 6, aber jetzt bei uns 4.
Also, ich kann das jetzt wohl aushalten,
aber es ist halt so ein bisschen diese Angst, die jetzt da bei mir mitspielt.
Das verstehe ich gut.
Okay.
Und die Schmerzen sind irgendwo hinaus.
Zum Beispiel in der linken Arm.
Okay.
Herr Willers, gibt es bestimmt Ausböse für die Schmerzen?
Ja, wie gesagt, sonst war das immer, wenn ich irgendwas gemacht habe,
wenn ich mich also sehr angestrengt habe.
Aber jetzt kann ich das eigentlich nicht sagen.
Ich habe jetzt nichts gemacht, deswegen wundert mich das so sehr.
Das ist mir jetzt mit einem mal so puh, oder schlecht geht.
Okay.
Und dann gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen etwas lindert, oder Herr Schiele-Mertz?
Also, kann ich jetzt nicht so richtig sagen,
mit der Zeit sind die Schmerzen ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Und normalerweise hört es eigentlich so spätestens nach einer halben Stunde,
hört es auf, aber jetzt hat es eben nicht aufgehört,
sondern war eigentlich immer noch da.
Und deshalb, das macht mir so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Husten?
Ja, ich habe aber schon seit langer Zeit eigentlich so ein chronischen Husten.
Ich nehme oft, wenn das so ganz unangenehm wird, mit dem Husten,
nehme ich ACC ein.
Das ist so schon mal ein Dauerbegleiter eigentlich.
Aber eigentlich, jetzt ist der Husten nicht schlimmer als sonst, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Und ist Ihre Husten mit Ausruf oder trocken?
Der ist eigentlich eher so trocken.
Haben Sie schon einmal unter Kurzatmung gelitten?
Unter Kurzatmung?
Ja, oder Atemnot.
Atemnot?
Ja, also direkt der Atemnot, dass ich so das Gefühl hatte,
ich muss so japsen, das habe ich nicht gehabt.
Nein.
Aber die Atemnot hat gerade angefangen oder?
Ja, vor zwei Stunden.
Vor zwei Stunden, genau.
Bevor, haben Sie, okay.
Ja, also da hatte ich eben dieses Gefühl,
dass es beim Einatmen diese Schmerzen schlechter sind.
Mhm, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Willatz, fühle Sie sich piblich?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht, würde ich nicht sagen.
Aber ich habe, als es losging, hatte ich das Gefühl,
dass ich mit einem so einen Schweißausbruch kriege, ja.
Das habe ich gemerkt, aber eigentlich so vom Kopf her fieberig
oder so fühle ich mich nicht.
Haben Sie schon einmal das Fieber gemessen?
Hab ich nicht gemessen, nee.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß?
Normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe Sie gerade gesagt.
Vorhin zu Beginn hatte ich das einmal,
als das so losging.
Da hatte ich das Gefühl,
mit einem, dass ich so einen Schweißausbruch habe.
Okay.
Ihnen übel oder schwindelig?
Übel ist mir, ja.
Also schlecht ist mir, ja.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, aber ich habe so das Gefühl,
essen könnte ich jetzt nichts.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Und ich würde Sie jetzt fragen,
wenn Ihnen übel war, müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Erblichen muss ich nicht.
Nein, doch nicht.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ich habe jetzt Fragen.
Ich muss jetzt fragen,
treten beim Stulgang oder Wasserlassen?
Schwierigkeiten auf?
Nein, in meinem Alter.
Ich bitte Sie.
Nein, nein, normalerweise ist alles okay.
Okay.
Falls Ihnen in diesem Sommer noch etwas,
das es wichtig sein könnte?
Ich habe Ihnen ja eigentlich alles erzählt,
was jetzt mit meinem, mit der Geschichte war.
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich Ihnen da noch erzählen könnte.
Okay, alles klar.
Alles klar.
Und auch, haben Sie Ihnen nächsten Zeit
stark abgenommen oder zugenommen?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen,
aber zugenommen auch nicht, nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Normalerweise ist es sehr gut,
aber heute ist es eher nicht, ja.
Okay. Heute leiden Sie unter Appetitlosigkeit.
Ja, also heute ist mir einfach schlecht
und jetzt würde ich nicht auf die Idee kommen,
was zu essen, ja.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Schwierigkeiten,
eine zu schlafen, oder?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, eine oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein, ich kann normalerweise gut schlafen, ja.
Manchmal, wenn es Stress gibt bei der Arbeit,
schlafe ich es nicht so gut ein.
Dann arbeitet das Nachts noch im Kopf so ein bisschen.
Okay, vielleicht.
Aber normalerweise würde ich sagen,
Sie können das manchmal nicht gut schlafen, ja.
Okay.
Okay. Herr Willers, sind bei Ihnen Allergien
oder Unterträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, so viel ich weiß.
Es gibt keine Allergien,
das ist noch nie etwas aufgefallen.
Okay.
Und gibt es Medikamente gegen die, die Allergien sind?
Also, da ist bisher noch nie etwas bemerkbar
und ich habe noch nie eine Allergie gehabt
auf Tabletten oder so.
Okay, alles wieder.
Herr Willers, brauchen Sie?
Ja.
Wie viele Skate brauchen Sie?
Ja, also früher habe ich eigentlich sehr mäßig geraucht.
Die ersten 20 Jahre konnte ich so ein Päckchen
über zwei Tage hinkommen.
Aber seit meiner Scheidung
und seit ein bisschen mehr Stress bei der Arbeit ist,
brauche ich ein Päckchen am Tag, würde ich sagen.
Das ist so seit drei Jahren.
Einschachtel im Tag, pro Tag.
Sie rauchen seit 20 Jahren oder mit 20 Jahren?
Nein, ich rauche, ich habe 20 Jahre lang,
habe ich ungefähr eine halbe Schachtel geraucht am Tag
und seit drei Jahren rauche ich eine Schachtel am Tag.
Also seit 23 Jahren.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, am Wochenende trinke ich mal ein paar Flaschen Bier
oder auch mal ein Wein, je nachdem, wenn es anders gibt.
Am Wochenende trinken Sie wieviel Gläser Alkohol?
Ja, also am Wochenende trinke ich schon so drei, vier Flaschen Bier.
Unter der Woche meistens eher nicht.
Okay, am Wochenende trinken Sie drei Klatsche Bier.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich auf,
darf ich fragen, ob Sie Drohlen nehmen?
Drohlen? Nein, das kann ich mir nicht erlauben bei meinem Beruf. Nein.
Okay.
Jetzt Herr Bielers, würde ich nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel
über Krankheiten oder...
Nein, sowas habe ich alles. Wie gesagt, dieser Husten, den ich seit 20 Jahren habe,
das hängt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mit dem rauchen auch zusammen.
Und wie gesagt, dann nehme ich den ATC, wenn es nicht mehr so gut ist, ne?
Okay.
Aber sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Okay, auch wenn ich...
Und, gehten Sie, um, äh, okay, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Oh ja, ich hatte mal ein Unterschenkel-Operation, weil ich wieder das Bein gebrochen habe.
Und das ist aber jetzt schon lange her, das ist schon vor 15 Jahren gewesen.
Und...
Und schon über wann sind, wann würden Sie operiert?
Das ist fünf vor 15 Jahren.
Vor 50 Jahren.
Gibt es noch andere Operations-Operationen?
Sonst bin ich noch nie operiert worden.
Okay, alles klar.
Äh, jetzt, nun möchte ich Sie nach Ihrer Familienfondgeschichte fragen.
Äh, äh, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, meine Mutter lebt noch.
Aber mein Vater, der ist, will ich sehr früh gestorben.
Der hatte, ähm...
Ich bin sehr leid.
Der hatte einen Herzinfarkt mit 65.
Und, ähm, das ist jetzt so fünf Jahre her, dann ist er relativ plötzlich verstorben, ja.
Ähm, sehr leid.
Ähm, darf ich Sie fragen, Ihre Vater an, äh,
Herzinfarkt, Herzinfarkt, Herzinfarkt,
äh, gestorben ist, oder?
Ja, er ist an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben, ja.
Ähm, okay.
Und ähm, äh, leidet Ihre Mutter.
Äh, an irgendeinem Erkrankung?
Ja, die hat so Gelenkprobleme, die hat so, so eine rheumatische Attritis.
Rheumatische Attritis.
Okay, alles klar.
Äh, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ich?
Ja.
Ja, ich nehme nur, wie gesagt, bei Bedarf, nämlich ACC, gegen, gegen diesen Husten,
aber sonst, dass ich regelmäßig, was weiß ich, wenn ich über Kopfschmerzen habe, oder so,
dann nehme ich mal Aspirin, aber sonst nehme ich nichts ein.
Okay.
Okay, ich nehme Husten, nehme ich mal direkt,
ah, ist das so, ah,
und ähm, äh, okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Äh, ich bin, äh, Speditionskaufmann.
Speditionskaufmann bin ich.
Okay.
Äh, jetzt schließe ich die Kaufmann.
Ähm, okay, sind Sie fürheidatet?
Nee, ich sagte ja schon, ich bin geschieden.
Und ähm,
warum sind Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter, die lebt auch bei mir.
Okay.
Eine Tochter lebt bei, lebt innen.
Herr Glas, ähm, ja, ich habe alle äh, wichtige Informationen schon in Gesamt.
Äh, hauen Sie noch Fragen oder,
ob es jetzt etwas, äh, das Sie mir äh, sagen möchten?
Ja, also jetzt fällt mir nichts mehr an.
Sie haben mir so viel gefragt, und ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt,
und, oh, das Einzige, was jetzt eigentlich ist,
dass ich, ich möchte gerne wissen,
ob ich jetzt hier im Krankenhaus bleibe,
dann müsste ich mal bei meiner Tochter anrufen.
Ja.
Dass sie sich keine Sorgen macht.
Und dann muss ich vielleicht auch gucken,
dass die irgendwie ein bisschen versorgt ist.
Aber sonst ähm,
ich möchte die Versorge.
Ja, wie machen wir jetzt weiter?
Wie geht es jetzt noch weiter?
Ja, ich möchte die Versorge.
Nun würde ich Sie über die weiteren Schilden informieren.
Ähm, ähm, erst mal,
Sie müssen bei uns bleiben.
Und dann, jetzt möchte ich,
möchte ich körperliche Untersuchung machen,
damit ich ähm,
meine Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen kann.
Und dann möchte ich Ihre Herz und Lungen
ähm, abhören.
Ähm, und danach nehme ich Ihren,
Ihren Blut ab.
Ähm, und äh,
ja, und ähm,
und danach kann ich Sie
äh, äh, äh,
worunter Sie leiten,
leiten, woran Sie leiten.
Ähm,
und, äh, ja,
wir haben schon IKG geschrieben.
Ähm, ja.
Okay, gut.
Dann, dann warte ich jetzt hier,
bis Sie wieder Zeit haben für mich, ne?
Okay.
Danke.
Danke für Ihre Arbeit.
Ich habe etwas dagegen eingenommen.
Ah, gute Frage.
Ähm, nein, hat ja nicht.
Er hat irgendwie so viel Sorge gehabt,
dass er gleich in die Klinik gekommen ist.
Hallo, äh, Sie haben gesagt,
äh, früher haben, äh,
hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwärme,
äh, äh, äh,
Könnten Sie uns sagen,
wie viel dauert diese Beschwärme?
Ja, Sie,
habe ich gesagt, längstens 30 Minuten.
Ja, okay.
Also eher kürzer, ne?
Und, äh, deswegen ist er jetzt auch in Sorge,
weil er, weil, weil das jetzt länger dauert.
Äh, waren Sie beim Arzt wegen dieser äh,
äh, äh, äh Beschwärme?
Hm, nee, ich hab es nicht so mit den Ärzten, ne?
Das merken Sie schon.
Nein, er ist nicht beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Könnten Sie bitte, bitte, äh,
bitte holen, äh,
wie waren diese früheren ähnlichen
in Bezug auf Dauer, Häufigkeit und schwere Grat?
Ja, also er hat, er hat das bei Belastung schon mal gehabt,
dass er so ein bisschen Schmerzen hatte und so ein enge Gefühl.
Äh, aber das war eben immer nach kurzer Zeit wieder weg
und es war nicht so heftig.
Haben Sie sotbrennen oder zauerstoff aus dem?
Nee, das hat er eigentlich nicht.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestartet.
Können wir als Erzelsgeschichte anfangen?
Äh, weil es war erst eine Mese.
Und das äh, stress, äh, äh,
Sti, äh, äh,
aber hat es doch gut gemacht.
Ja, aber, aber es war, es war schon äh,
ja, jetzt gucken wir, die, die Hürde,
die Hürde ist ja echt das Art-Arzt-Gespräch.
Ja, der Mese ist eigentlich immer gut.
Und jetzt kommt das Art-Arzt-Gespräch.
Ja, äh, unsere Patiente hat Düsseldorf-Fälle.
Hat was?
Düsseldorf-Fälle, diese Fall.
Äh, Fulöram-Wimps, das heißt.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Ja.
Na ja.
Ja, Sie kennen sie alle.
Ja.
Dr., Dr. Gündes kennen sie alle.
Ja, ich habe gerade geguckt.
Den habe ich das erste Mal, Juni 22 gemacht.
Ja.
Ja, gut.
Können wir Art-Arzt-Gespräch anfangen, Ernest?
Noch ein bisschen.
Noch ein bisschen, da gut, kein Problem.
Ich denke, äh, okay.
Ja?
Ja, guten Tag, Liegen Böck.
Ja, guten Tag.
Gut, guten Tag.
Guten Tag, Liegen Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Meine Name ist Dr. Erdurt.
Ähm, wenn Sie Zeit hätten, würde ich gerne einen neuen Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, klar. Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Mhm, okay.
Äh, ja.
Nein.
Ja, nein.
Nein, nein.
Nein.
für Hinterbrutzbein und für kurze Zeit habe er unter Atemnot gelitten und die beschwerten.
Herr Doktor, sagen Sie mir einmal den Fachbegriff für diese Schmerzen.
Ja, angina pektus.
Wo sind die lokalisiert?
Brutzbein, Hinterbrutzbein.
Ja, wie sagen wir dazu?
Wie heißt das Brutzbein?
Retrosternale Schmerzen.
Retrosternale Schmerzen, ja.
Aufgerät.
Retrosternale Schmerzen.
Ja, Retrosternale Schmerzen.
Und für Kurse Zeit habe er unter Atemnot gelitten und die Beschwerten seien lustig aufgetreten,
nach der Arbeit aufgetreten und ungefähr 30 Minuten gedauert.
Prüher haben Sie 30 Minuten geliebt.
Und sind Sie seit zwei Stunden?
Prüher.
Ja, mehr als zwei Stunden gedauert.
Und normalerweise leiden er bei Schmerzen ähnliche Beschwerten.
Und leider leiden er bei Schmerzen sei belaßt abhängig, wenn er anstrengend wird.
Wenn er sich anstrengt?
Wenn er anstrengend ist, tritt diese Beschwerten auf.
Am Anfang, diese Schmerzen seien heftig, aber im Laufe der Zeit verbessert.
Und am Anfang und den Patienten zufolge liegen die Schmerzen am Anfang auf eine Schmerzgala bei 6,
aber jetzt bei 2 oder 3.
Bei 2 bis 3.
Und die Schmerzen strahlen in linken Arm aus.
In den linken Arm?
Ja, und er berichtete, dass er seit längerer Zeit unter chronischen Husten leide.
Und er führte hin zu, dass er riecht kein Atemnot gehabt habe.
Und die Fragen nach Fieber, Erbrechen, Gewichtnahme oder Gewichtperlose wurden verneint.
Aber er gab Arm unter Übelkeit zu leiden.
Immer oder nur jetzt?
Jetzt.
Und unter Übelkeit zu leiden.
Aber er wendte auf, dass er kein Erbrechen habe.
Er musste sich nicht übergeben.
Er musste nicht übergeben.
Das ist ja schon mal was.
Er sagte, dass er über Insomnia wegen Schiitresklage.
Aber da war er?
Nein, manchmal.
Er war in Insomnia.
Er war nicht allergisch und keine Unterdrecklichkeiten.
Aber bei der noch so eine Nese gab es sich, die Nikotin Konsum seit 20 Jahren,
halbgeschafft und seit den letzten 3 Jahren einschafft.
Pro Tag.
Am Wochenende trink er 3 Fleisch Bier und kein Broden.
An Erkrankungen leide er an chronischen Pusten und seit 20 Jahren.
Ansonsten ist es unabhängig.
Er wurde unter Schenkel-Operation wegen Bruch des Beins untersorgend.
Er wurde unter Schenkel-Operation untersorgend.
Er wurde operiert.
Wie lange ist diese Operation her?
Die Operation wurde vor 15 Jahren untersorgend.
Er wurde in der Familie der Nese bei den Vater und der Vater gestorben.
Bei der Mutter ist er bekannt.
Er war als Spitzkaufmann.
Er ist geschieden und hat eine Tochter.
Er ist als Spitzkaufmann.
Ich habe noch eine wichtige Frage.
Er ist die Elevation.
Er ist über die Übelkeit und Schmerzen auf die Pirite.
Er ist auf die Hinterwand.
Was machen Sie denn mit den Patienten?
Manchmal ist es bemerkbar.
Was machen Sie denn mit den Augen oder mit den Händen?
Was gucken Sie denn da?
Manchmal ist es bemerkbar.
Was gucken Sie denn im Labor?
Wo hin überweisen?
Das wäre der nächste Schritt, dass mein Herz katheter macht.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich habe schon gesagt, Ihre Anamnese war sehr schön.
Der schwierigere Teil ist immer das Arztgespräch.
Da haben Sie sich aber auch sehr wacker geschlagen.
Ein paar allgemeine Sachen, die etwas mit der Sprache zu tun haben, wollte ich Ihnen sagen.
Einmal im Zusammenhang mit der OP.
Man kann sagen, ein Patient wurde operiert.
Man kann sagen, das ist dann reflexiv.
Dann ist er eindeutig impassiv.
Er wurde operiert.
Er wurde blintern Operation unterzogen.
Man kann sagen, ich bin nicht der Patient.
Man kann sagen, ich gehe dahin und sage, bitte operiert meine Varizen.
Ich würde das immer eindeutig formulieren.
Manchmal Kollegen, das wissen die Leute meistens, gerade wenn das Sachen aus der letzten Zeit sind.
Operationen, was sagen Sie immer?
Nein, die Operationen sind nicht bekannt.
Wenn man operiert wurde, weiß man das meistens.
Irgendeine Narbe bleibt in irgendeiner Stelle.
Im Gedächtnis weiß man das meistens auch noch, dass man mal eine Operation hatte.
Dann könnte man höchstens sagen, die Operationen wurden keine Angaben dazu gemacht.
Zustand nach.
Dann, das war auch witzig.
Er sagte, dass er über Insumni klage.
Der Patient klagt über aktuelle Beschwerden.
Klage heißt immer, sich über etwas beschweren oder etwas als Wiedrigkeit.
Er beschreibt eine Gelegenliche Insumni unter Stress.
Er klagt seit acht Jahren über rezidivierende Bauchschmerzen.
Er klagt nicht seit acht Jahren, sondern über Bauchschmerzen, die seit acht Jahren rezidivierend sind.
Er klagt aktuell über irgendetwas.
Er klagt über etwas, das schon lange besteht.
Er klagt nicht seit acht Jahren, sondern über etwas, das möglicherweise lange besteht.
Er sagt, dass er über Insumni klage.
Das würde ich so nicht schreiben.
Dann haben Sie sich schwer getan bei der Gewichtsveränderung.
Da haben Sie gesagt, er hat Gewicht nicht zugenommen, aber auch nicht abgenommen.
Da kann man auch sehr elegant sagen, sein Gewicht hat sich in letzter Zeit nicht verändert.
Den Patienten kann man gut fragen, haben Sie in letzter Zeit zu oder abgenommen?
Dann kann man das entweder genau so sagen, er hat in letzter Zeit weder zu noch abgenommen.
Oder man sagt, er beschreibt keine Gewichtsveränderung in letzter Zeit.
Das waren diese Geschichten.
Sie haben diese Übergänge sehr schön gemacht.
Das hat mir gut gefallen bei der Anamnese.
Am Anfang habe ich zu Ihren Personalien gefragt.
Dann sprechen wir über Ihre Beschwerden.
Dann haben Sie zugemacht und gesagt, Sie wollen mir zu Ihren Beschwerden noch etwas sagen.
Sie haben über Lebensbedingungen und Familienanamnese gesprochen.
So sind Sie bei dem Bericht auch ganz schön vorgegangen.
Sie haben das schön geordnet, wie Sie es auch abgefragt haben.
Das ist immer ein guter Weg.
Wenn Sie es noch mal anhören, werden Sie merken, dass Sie bei den Fragen deutlich flüssiger formuliert haben als nachher ein Bericht.
Das ist typisch, das geht allen so.
Dass das der einfache Part ist und nachher der Bericht.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass Sie sehr gut verstanden haben, wenn ich irgendwelche Rückfragen hatte.
Was Sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen beachten müssen, dass Sie in dem Arztgespräch verstärkt Fachbegriffe benutzen.
Ja, Sie haben das nicht.
Das erwarten die Prüfer immer.
Dr. Gündes ist ein paar Mal eingestiegen, ich auch ein paar Mal.
Von vornherein, das einfach mitliefern und unter Umständen bei den Notizen schon gleich beides aufschreiben.
Dann sind Sie eigentlich auf der sicheren Seite.
Eigentlich ist das ein wichtiger Punkt, dass man das auch unterscheidet sprachlich.
Das nicht Fachgespräch mit dem Patienten, wo wir seine Wortwahl und seine Begriffe ausnehmen.
Und auf der anderen Seite das Fachgespräch, wo wir oft ja mit einem Wort ganz präzise etwas beschreiben können.
Ja, bestimmt.
Jetzt Beispiel, diese retro-ständalen Schmerzen, das ist hier so ein Klassiker eingemacht.
Ja, das ist ja eine Klassiker.
Ja, das war es.